hey Mahmoud can you help me read this
Arabic message I got I can't recognize
any of the words oh that's not Arabic
hello everyone welcome to the line
focused channel my name is Paul in a
recent video I talked about the Persian
language which is spoken in Iran
Afghanistan and Tajikistan because Iran
is located in the Middle East next to
Iraq a lot of people wonder if the
Persian language and Arabic are related
well they are not directly related but
they have influenced each other
Persian and Arabic belonged to
completely different language families
which means that they have separate
origins Arabic is a Semitic language and
it comes from the same root language as
Hebrew Aramaic Phoenician Ugaritic etc
Persian on the other hand is an
indo-european language that shares
common roots with the languages of
northern India as well as most of the
languages in Europe such as English
French and German
therefore Persian and Arabic have very
different grammar and the way that words
are constructed is completely different
Semitic languages have a unique system
of mostly three-letter roots and these
three-letter roots are put into
templates that form the shape of
different words for example the Arabic
root for learn which in English is like
DRS if you want to say I learn you take
those 3 root letters and you add them
into this template here and say a Druce
persian does not have this system of
putting the root into templates the root
words stay in one piece and affixes are
attached to it so let's look at an
example in Persian using the root word
dong which means no the first word is
Donna Stan which means to know so if we
add the FX s Stan that creates the
infinitive of the verb the next word is
Dhanesh which means knowledge
so the affix H creates an abstract noun
then if we take that word and we add
another affix at the end
Daanish monde that means scientist so
that creates a concrete noun so you can
see that nothing is changing with the
root word itself the root word done
doesn't change the letters don't get
separated the way they would in Arabic
there are a couple of their differences
that I think show that Persian has
simpler grammar than Arabic one of the
differences is Persian language only has
two grammatical cases and only one of
them is actually marked
whereas Arabic has three grammatical
cases and all three of them are marked
and now the difference is that Persian
doesn't have any grammatical gender
there's no feminine masculine or neuter
nouns which is quite a relief to some of
us so the origins of Arabic and Persian
are unrelated and structurally they are
completely different languages there are
two main similarities between Persian
and Arabic the script and the vocabulary
except for the Persian that is spoken in
Tajikistan which is written in the
Cyrillic script Persian is written in a
modified form of the Arabic script so
what is modified about it well in the
Persian language they have some sounds
that you can't find in the Arabic
language so they needed to create some
new letters that represent those sounds
there are four of these new letters in
the Persian version of the Arabic script
they actually come from Arabic letters
but the markings above or below the
letters are different in Arabic there is
no P sound but in Persian there is a
piece ound so they created this new
letter to represent the P sound
they took the Arabic letter form but the
B sound and they added two more dots
underneath that letter so when we see
that we know it's a pup and in standard
Arabic there is no juts out so they took
the Arabic letter for Jo and they added
two more dots under the letter that
represents cha there is also no sound in
Standard Arabic so they took the Arabic
letter for Z the Z sound and they added
two more dots above the letter and that
makes a sure like the French Jay Arabic
also has no letter for guff the hard G
sound so Persian took the letter for cut
the K sound and they added an extra line
above it and that represents guff the
hard G sound and some of the other
letters represent slightly different
sounds too for example the letter wow in
Arabic becomes love in Persian I almost
said Hebrew there because the letter is
also called volve in modern Hebrew
because of the use of this modified
Arabic script people who can't read it
just take one look at it and because it
looks the same they think that it's
Arabic or they think that it's the same
as Arabic but anyone who's able to read
the script or even just know the letters
they'll quickly realize that this is not
Arabic because you see letters that you
don't find an Arabic and also of course
the words are different
probably not all of the words are
different that's because Persian has a
whole lot of Arabic loanwords in it that
stretch all the way back to the Islamic
conquest of Persia in literary Persian
as much as 40% of the vocabulary is of
Arabic origin but in colloquial speech
the percentage of Arabic words is much
lower so even though lots of words have
been adopted from arabic into persian
the structure of those Arabic words has
not been adopted they're simply adopted
as vocabulary as they are and then they
are treated as Persian words once
they're adopted basically the words that
are borrowed are not broken down into
the roots which is how they would be
treated in Arabic and the loanwords have
also adapted to the phonology of the
Persian language so now they often sound
quite different here are some example
loan words good morning in arabic is
saba hala hala
good morning in Persian is Subba hey
hello in Persian is Salam which comes
from Salam in Arabic so you notice that
the second a sounds a little bit like an
O in English kind of like Shalom
actually the Arabic word for name is ism
in Persian it's SM so just the first
vowel is different in Arabic the word
for travel is safar in Persian it's
safar in Arabic the word for teaching is
2 Alim in persian it's 2 aleem so you'll
notice that the ioan sound from arabic
kind of disappears and becomes a simple
glottal stop the Arabic word for without
is Badoon in Persian it's Badu net the
Arabic word for history is Talia the
Persian where it is Talia so just the
first a vowel seems shorter the Arabic
word for first is a well but in Persian
it's a vowel so there we have the Wow
becoming pronounced like a valve
there are also Persian loan words that
have entered the Arabic language though
not as many there are some in Standard
Arabic but there are more in some of the
Arabic dialects that are located near
Iran especially in Iraqi Arabic but
Persian words in Arabic are harder to
identify because when they're borrowed
into Arabic they're taken apart and
their root is placed into Arabic
templates to make new arabised words
Persian and Arabic are different
languages that are not mutually
intelligible but my understanding is
that native speakers here the other
language and they recognize quite a few
of the words that they hear but they
don't get the overall message is it easy
for a Persian speaker to learn Arabic
and vice versa well it's the large
amount of shared vocabulary will
definitely help in the same way that an
English speaker learning French has an
automatic advantage because of all the
shared vocabulary that is especially
helpful for receptive skills of course
you still have the challenge of learning
how to produce correct sentences in the
grammar of the other language thank you
for watching the Lang focus channel I
hope that was helpful leave your
comments down below and have a nice day